hey friends welcome back to deep dive
what you're about to hear is a
conversation between me and my business
coach hassan cooper who is in fact also
the author of this book the unfair
advantage which won the business book
awards business book of the year in
2021. we talk a little bit about the
book about the concepts of this unfair
advantages framework and then we spend
most of the conversation talking about
the idea of having a business life coach
and why it's a good thing for most
people and then the episode kind of
turns into a mini coaching session where
husson coaches me on issues that i'm
facing in my life and we try and figure
out a way of how you as the watcher or
the listener can apply these coaching
frameworks to your own life without
needing to hire someone like a life or
business coach in the episode we also
talk about the idea of limiting beliefs
we talk a little bit about productivity
and procrastination we talk about
confidence and we talk about how to find
your unfair advantages so sit back relax
and i hope you enjoy the conversation it
feels great to do this interview because
we know each other quite well yeah and
so i feel like
once those guys leave the room i feel
like this will just be more of a
conversation and i can ask you about the
things that i'm curious about nice um so
let's start with uh
we are we're we're working on a
collaborative e-type video together
about like you being my coach for some
number of months yeah and the stuff that
i've learned from that yeah and you've
put some bullet points together but like
it was so long ago that we started
working together like a year ago almost
almost to this date and i really can't
remember what were the main like
epiphanies yeah i'm very curious like
having having gone through the footage
and like done run the sessions a what
was it like coaching me and what were
like the epiphanies that i had and i'm
asking because then people listening to
this might have similar epiphanies in
their life sure yeah no it was really
interesting the going through all of
that and looking at it and unfortunately
we weren't recording the earlier
sessions but i took really extensive
notes so i was looking through the notes
and stuff um
what was interesting is how much you
figured out just in that first session
so the first session i still remember
you were you were in a cafe just a
random coffee shop and it was we had
just come out of a lockdown or something
for the autumn
uh 2020 and
in that session we did some exercises so
you talk about the odyssey plan a lot
and we did something very similar in
that session and we also spoke about i
just was asking what do you want to
achieve and you're like ah you know i
don't i don't like goals and you have
the same squirming thing about goals now
but but you have evolved a lot in terms
of like how you view goals and how you
see it as a
having a direction having a destination
matters you know it's all about the
journey but the destination still
matters so one of the things that you
said which was very interesting was um
i want to have
more uh over 50
of the revenue and this was kind of a
very business goal over 50 of the
revenue
coming uh from a platform that i control
so not from skillshare and youtube
and and basically i was like oh cool
have you thought about this already
you're like no i literally just thought
of that now and within about three
months
since the launch of ptya or something
there abouts you'd achieved it basically
which is so cool and also the limiting
beliefs that he had was very interesting
oh what limiting beliefs do i have oh
about like
i can't charge a lot of money for my
course it feels weird it feels like
selling snake oil and actually
i gave you i brought you snake all today
because you thought that was really
funny i saw it in dubai yeah and um and
i brought you some george can you check
us the bottle of snakehole that we can
we can
show this was like your num this is
snake oil
[Laughter]
thank you for buying me some snake oil
from dubai yeah you're welcome man so
this
i hope it cures everything for you it's
going to cure everything i think i'm
going to leave it in its packaging yeah
and then like maybe try and nftify it or
something like that
unfortunately that's a great idea so
filling snake oil i don't mean to have
it displayed alongside your book which
i'm sure is not not at all related to
the idea of snake oil but
exactly so yeah you were really worried
about selling snake oil and i think a
lot of people
to be honest i'll be very suspicious of
anybody who didn't have that fear at all
basically if you're selling especially
when it comes to like information online
and usually what happens is when we
develop some kind of
experience expertise especially when it
comes to business like you can be like
three years into a business and you
could have made massive progress but
this was my experience and the
experience of a lot of entrepreneurs i
know is you take it for granted because
you're just looking at people ahead of
you and you're just looking at what
you're going to do next and you still
haven't and always the goal line is
always moving and even if you haven't
explicitly set goals you're always kind
of like thinking about the next thing
you want to hit the next milestone yeah
it's like you're measuring the the gap
rather than the gain the gap rather than
the gain yeah and even if you haven't i
mean the gap is when you have a set goal
but even if you haven't got a set goal i
guess you just look for the next round
number no exactly like i remember when i
when i was first sitting at the youtube
academy and i was chatting to
um our mutual friends thiago and david
who run courses as well and i was saying
like why why would anyone want to hear
from me about how to grow on youtube
i've only got 1.2 million subscribers
and they were they were just like
laughing they were like bro
that's actually a large number and i was
like but like you know mr beast has like
50 million subscribers yeah but like you
know
like
you can teach people the process that
you use to get to 1 million subscribers
and people would find that very useful
yeah even if there are other people out
there that are further ahead in the
journey than you yeah and i i actually
see this a lot um i see this a lot
amongst doctors so now that i'm i'm
doing this youtube thing i've spoken to
a bunch of medics uh who want to create
educational content related to medicine
one of my one of my friends is a
cardiothoracic uh kind of surgeon in
training
and he wants to make content helping
other wannabe cardiothoracic surgeons
kind of about their exams and all that
kind of stuff but his concern is well
i'm not the ultimate ultimate big dog
person and i have to wait until i fully
qualify to be a consultant as a
consultant and then i can teach stuff
but then at that point it's gonna be oh
well i'm just a new consultant i have to
have to wait until i have i'm the
chairman of the board of cardiothoracic
surgeons and then i'm allowed to make
stuff exactly and it just keeps on going
pushing further and further and further
forward because we all have this like
imposter syndrome of like i am not yet
qualified to do this thing absolutely
and then at some point in the future i
will become qualified to do this thing
but the goal post keeps shifting
and actually when you have just overcome
it's just that whole thing of like
being a guru versus being a guide and
actually being a guru is not always the
best it might have it might be better in
terms of marketing you get people's
attention more because if you're the
best if usain bolt wants to teach you
how to run that's interesting people get
people to do a master class but then it
might come so naturally to him that he's
going to not relate to a complete
beginner who just doesn't he's just like
uh so i think the people who are hard
gainers are the best teachers
and i think that is actually so our
coaching then evolved into book coaching
so we started off we did like six months
of kind of business general kind of
coaching but then it became like book
coaching specifically and one of the
challenges that you had is like
okay so
where do because you've had obviously
everybody has struggles but there are
some things that came much more easily
to you in terms of like productivity or
in terms of procrastination or whatever
it is so it's like
first of all you need to highlight where
you had trouble to make that and
secondly go think and basically think
remember what it felt like to be to be
going through that trouble so remember
what it felt like to start youtube
remember if i like to start a business
and those are the things that are
like really difficult to do and it's so
easy to forget what a beginner feels the
fear the
the lack
the lack of context so it's that curse
of knowledge where when you once you
know something it's you think it's so
obvious that i've got nothing to teach
it's just so obvious isn't it so whereas
we all have our own perspective or we we
worry that we're not original we worry
we don't have enough content and reality
is i think part of that comes from just
understanding how much value you can add
so once you put into a position where
you're actually helping or mentoring
mentoring is actually very helpful
coaching mentoring because then you go
oh okay i can actually add loads of
value and actually if you learn coaching
frameworks you can even add value
without having the ex domain expertise
in the thing itself so you coach a bunch
of people like what is a what is a
coaching framework how does that work
coaching so coaching is really
interesting because i've had a whole
journey of like coming to terms with
like believing that coaching is valuable
because
one way that a consultant explained
coaching to me earlier on in my journey
when i was like a year or two into
business i hired this consultant and she
was like to me okay so a consultant do
you know the difference between the
consultant and the coach and i was like
no like what's the difference she said a
consultant gives you answers and a coach
gives you more questions i was like oh
okay coaching sounds really stupid then
like how annoying is that you ask a
question why would you pay someone so
much money just to ask you ask you
questions yeah
what's more annoying than asking a
question and getting one in return it's
like can you just tell me like what is
going on so i always thought no you know
what um coach is an unregulated term um
there are every top they can harry on
like linkedin is like a life coach or
whatever something coach and you just
think well these 20 year old life
coaches what the hell do they know and
you just think it's like crap so i
always
like stayed away from it but what made
the shift for me is starting to
understand and we were actually
mentoring early stage startup founders
and we were just kind of
we didn't know any coaching or mentoring
frameworks we just did what comes
naturally you just give people the
answer you tell people what to do you
give them advice you tell them okay this
is what i did in your situation and then
you start i started to learn more about
coaching in the value of asking
questions and getting like the coachee
to figure out the answer to really think
about it it's almost like showing you're
working in like maths when you did math
at school it's like jumping to giving a
student the answer straight away isn't
going to help them so
the coaching is really valuable to do
that so i think that like the two main
benefits of coaching
is
number one is clarity because getting
asked those questions back about what
you're trying to achieve what you're
trying to avoid why and then just keep
do we keep being asked why it's very
valuable and by the way if you guys see
some of the episodes of ali with tamora
and not overthinking you'll see coaching
in action because ali you've been doing
that quite a bit and it's been fun to
see um so a coaching framework to answer
so clarity is number one number two is
accountability so clarity and
accountability are the two main benefits
of coaching a coaching framework is
simply taking somebody through the idea
of like okay what are you looking to do
what what you're looking to achieve
what what do you want okay right
asking why what you're looking to avoid
asking why and then okay based on that
what do you think is your next action
what's the highest leverage thing you
could do okay so what are you trying to
achieve
what do you why what are you trying to
avoid why okay now that you've got this
data what's the next action that you
want to take
and this is this is a very simple
framework i call it aaa
achieve avoid act what do you want to
avoid act aaa approach so how would
would how would you apply this to me
let's say we want to sort of switch this
into a where we're in coaching mode now
how would how would that conversation
start so i'll just be like okay at least
first i'll just get some context and
build imagine if we didn't know each
other bill said before how are you doing
and just see what comes up and that's
kind of just getting a pulse of the
situation right now that's just context
and then you from there you get into
like okay so what are you looking to
achieve right now
and i like to leave it quite broad okay
i'd like to leave it quite broad and
then sometimes they go in what area and
it's just interesting to see what comes
up right so what are you looking to
achieve right now what am i looking to
achieve right now we are going to take a
little quick break from the podcast to
introduce the sponsor of this podcast
which is curiosity stream if you haven't
heard by now curiosity streams is the
world's leading documentary streaming
subscription platform founded by john
hendricks who's the founder of the
discovery channel and on curiositystream
they've got hundreds of really high
quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of this
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is this service called nebula
which you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available on
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiosity stream love supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity streams
incredible library of documentaries and
also free access to all of the stuff on
nebula bundled with that so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive to get the bundle deal so thank you
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episode okay so in my head i'm just
going to show you my working in my head
part of me is like i'm looking to
achieve a clearer calendar i'm looking
to achieve time that i can focus on the
book i'm looking to achieve figuring out
what i actually want to say in the book
i'm looking to achieve figuring out like
what i need to do to hand off like the
running of the business responsibilities
to angus who is now running the business
side of things so i can focus on the
content i'm thinking of i need to
achieve some sort of process with
working with our writers a videographer
and youtube producer to
create content that feels authentic to
me that will also potentially be
valuable to others in a way that
still keeps me showing up in the content
and not just like offloading all of it
to kind of writers because i think it's
important for me to be involved in it
and i'm thinking that how can i do i
want to do all these things and also
have time to sleep eight hours a night
and have a bit of a social life and play
like squash once a week and go to the
gym twice a week that's sort of what
i've got in my head nice that's like
things i'm trying to achieve and because
i know you already and we've done
coaching before i know that actually if
you if you notice that all triangulates
upon this
sort of uh process oriented goal well
number one one outcome goal is the book
and that always comes up when i've asked
you what's the biggest thing for you
right now who's got the book and
understandably your book is a big
project and you want to make it good and
it takes a lot of cognitive kind of
labor to really get into it but secondly
if you notice that you're kind of trying
to clear out your calendar to work on
the book to have creative space to have
that time and your it's part of that is
lifestyle design as well and how do you
and then you've got some things in there
about like keep the business running
keep that going smoothly and how do you
have the right amount of input
into your videos and not completely
abdicate how do you delegate and not
abdicate basically um so yeah so this is
and then what we can go into is is why
and why you're getting into that and
then we can go into okay what are you
looking to avoid and sometimes that
comes up already and sometimes people
when you ask them what you're looking to
avoid they start talking about what they
want to achieve again and it's very
interesting and what i love about this
process is because i come from a
background of marketing so my first
business was a marketing agency and
actually these are the kinds of things
that you need to figure out for your you
know customer avatar you need to figure
out what are they looking to achieve
what are they looking to avoid and
what's coming up for them and you have
to enter the conversation that's going
on in their minds and really if you boil
that down to what it actually is it's
how do you motivate people
so marketing is motivation and coaching
in a way is just motivation it's how do
you most it's clarity and then
motivation and so you're looking to get
the whole so my coach did it recently so
i've been dog fooding essentially they
say that in startup worlds of like
eating having your own product which is
i've become this recent convert to
coaching like it's been a year now and
and i've got an executive coach i've got
a health coach i've got like a coach to
help me get organized with notion so my
health coach recently um reasserted
we're kind of getting close to the 17
week program so it was the end now and
i've already lost like five kilos i'm
fee i'm like you're asking me what did i
have for breakfast nothing because i'm
just like like i'm doing the whole thing
of getting back into shape getting back
into my ideal way etc so one of the
things that he's did to me what he
because i i actually had a bit of a
cheat weekend
and one of the things he said to me on
the week on on monday and and it didn't
have too bad of a knock-on effect
because i didn't go too hard on it and i
was quite happy because i'm quite
metabolically flexible i could do that
and then still get back on track and
have steady energy and be a fat burner
so one thing that he asked me is
so remin so why is it that you wanna
he he went back to what you're trying to
achieve i go okay well i'd like to fit
into my large clothes again instead of
excel that felt terrible to not know
what to wear and to feel confident from
the camera to feel confident on stage
etc and he's like what would it feel
like if you don't get there what would
it feel like if you do and actually i
found those really difficult difficult
questions i felt very like
ah okay i have to like touch in with my
emotions of how that's gonna feel okay
but it really helped like he forced me
to do it okay so how would that feel if
you if you had to wear xxl clothing
clothing
it just it just feels like such a
failure because i've been talking about
it for so long so one of the things
about finding enough about health and
fitness and stuff particularly nutrition
i was into this 10 years ago and
everyone used to be like the hassan diet
before like
the whole like um primal paleo keto that
that world
i was like very early into that world i
was telling everybody that butter is
actually quite healthy before anybody
really believed it until like now people
are starting to agree with that i used
to drink bulletproof coffee before that
was like
trendy so everybody's so if anybody
hasn't seen me for a very long time
they're like oh my god what happened to
you because i was really slim yeah and
so
so that
i think is the identity thing and this
is because of a lot of introspection i'm
into self-development but i think the
identity thing of like
come on hassan you used to be the one
who used to give people advice and
inspire people to get into shape and now
you're like gained weight you're
overweight you've locked down as an
excuse you've moved house renovations
all this kind of stuff
so it feels really so so you tied your
identity to the idea of being someone
who is slim who gives people advice on
how to be healthy i mean not not kind of
not on purpose okay i mean oh right yeah
i didn't do that on purpose but like as
in part of that it's like and also
um if you're out there giving advice
like one stay even if it's nothing to do
with it one thing that i've learned just
as a coach in general um is you want to
be like you're without meaning to be and
i think you've experienced this yourself
because you're a role model without
trying to be a role model yeah and it's
like as much as you don't want it
you have people are going to look up to
you and they're going to look at other
parts of your life even though you're
not saying oh i've got these other parts
of my life
all you know
optimized and i'm doing so well in them
maybe there are areas of your life where
you need work on but they'll still look
at them so if you're teaching people
about i don't know being productive but
you're um you're really like overweight
people will be like huh he doesn't have
his [ __ ] together in that other aspect
and i think nowadays it's becoming more
and more like you have to be more
well-rounded there you don't get really
fat ceos as much anymore like people who
are really unhealthy or overweight
people really think of that holistical
holistic kind of being in shape so these
are all the things that drove me and so
being reminded of that really motivated
me to be like okay this is why i need to
stick with it and i didn't feel like i
needed it at that point but it was very
powerful is okay so in in that context
um if i if i can summarize and please
feel free to correct me yeah if this is
not what's going on it sounds like
you
you feel like you're getting fat you
have your identity tied to accidentally
tied to someone who is slim and someone
who's got their life together someone
who's healthy being fat in in your view
world view is not that and therefore
you're targeting the being fat thing
is it not more like is it not healthier
to target the root cause whereby your
own self-love is not actually related to
your weight ultimately is the thing you
want to cultivate being a healthy weight
or is it thing you want to cultivate
being happy with yourself
in which case you could either change
the
change your weight
or you could change your the expectation
you have on your weight if that makes
sense of course yeah and that is
something that i really think about it's
the value system it's like underneath
all of that it's like
why am i doing am i just doing it
because society tells me i need to be a
certain weight that would be a very
unhealthy
or potentially extremely unhealthy way
of looking at it and definitely i
wouldn't do it for that reason alone
a big piece of this which i haven't
spoken about which i've spoken to my
health coach about a lot is productivity
is energy levels and i know that i've
noticed it like you're much more
lethargic when you gain weight just
overall like you your body just isn't as
energized it isn't just as energetic so
that's a big piece of it why do you
value productivity
so again i've done a lot of work on this
and i think it's it goes down and i know
i've just come back from dubai i've just
come back from a trip first trip abroad
in over two years because of covid and
the book launch and all of that before
that um and really
i was like thinking okay what am i doing
this for now i'm comfortable i've i'm
i'm fine like now what am i doing this
for and i think this goes back to
like as and then you get into the cheesy
stuff but really it goes back to like i
feel like i've found my unfair advantage
it's taking me till almost age 30 when i
figured out communication
and
writing and creating content is actually
something i'm really good at even though
i don't have that much practice in so
clearly there's some kind of underlying
talent there and i go into that in the
book of like i believe in talent and
this is a big shift from when i was
younger and imbibing so much
self-development and motivational videos
and stuff which is to say it's not about
talent it's just about working hard you
just got to work really hard talent
doesn't exist i think no it does and you
have to find yours and it might take
time and you have to experiment and it
might not be so obvious straight away et
cetera that's part of self-awareness
yeah which is a huge part of coaching is
self-awareness is developing that so i
feel like i've got this gift and i want
to share it okay it's it goes down to
that so once you have all your basic
needs met your maslow's hierarchy of
knees are all there then you're like
okay self-actualization
and that's why i want to be more
productive because it makes me happier
and as lame as this sounds and this
sounds very toxic but i'm really not
actually if you look at me i'm very in
my life i have a very clear delineation
between work time and chill out time and
i actually usually don't work at all
after 6 p.m like at all so
i'm actually i've approached business
from the beginning to try to be that way
now the first two years setting up the
business was quite hard um was doing
long hours deadlines make clients happy
etc but i've always had this mindset of
being able to cut off and i'm actually
quite good at that but but
my moods are dictated by how productive
i've been that day oh interesting yeah
they really are like if i've been having
a bad day it's usually because i haven't
done the work that i wish i would have
done like i haven't
actually sat but it makes me happy as
well and i don't think it's purely just
me thinking oh i just need to be
productive like
writing
or creating actually makes me happy and
i've only recently started speaking of
identity i've only recently started
thinking of myself as a creative person
i never thought of myself as that and i
don't know if you had a similar thing
because i think i kind of identified a
bit with the
word nerd when i was younger and i was
good at science and maths and i never
thought of myself as a creative is that
something that you've had a shift in as
well or is that kind of always been
there for you yeah i mean i still don't
think of myself as a creative
i think i'm really bad at coming up with
ideas um i think you're a creator i'm a
creator yeah but i be
because i create things but i'm not
creative in that
i think creative the adjective is like
feels feels to me like something that
i'm not i think i'm pretty productive
but i wouldn't say i'm particularly
creative i mean what's what's helped me
go over that yeah you're describing is
the whole picasso thing of like good
artists copy great artists steal and
learning that actually design arts all
of that is all from influences and
nothing comes from scratch
and yeah like for example ash my
co-author he's he's super creative like
he could he can brainstorm anything and
he could just come up with new things
i'm not to that level but i'm really
good at synthesis and i think you're
really good at synthesis we have a lot
of that in common actually in terms of
like getting different ideas that we
imbibe and then putting it together into
our own model i think you're very good
and that is a creative thing i mean
people like us we love teaching right we
love giving advice and we have to just
stop ourselves constantly telling other
people this is what you should try this
is what you should do
because a lot of the time when we're
doing that we haven't done enough
listening to unders to what we do is we
assume they're like us we assume their
goals are like us we assume we
understood their goals we assume and so
we're giving an answer but reality is we
haven't done enough listening and enough
work before beforehand to even give an
answer and actually a good consultant
would spend so much time trying to
figure out what's the goal what the why
and all that stuff anyway let alone when
you're coaching so it's uh it's just one
of those instincts to constantly and
that's one thing i teach my students so
one of the things that i did is i
launched uh so coaching went into group
coaching went into like a
an online course right i've run called
transformational creator and one of the
things i've told the students on there
is
how to coach because as a way to figure
out if there is really a market for what
you're trying to do in this case they're
creators and they're trying to create
like
become
build their personal brands become
experts in the field become thought
leaders etc but it's like teaching them
how when they talk to people not to just
constantly give them advice and be doing
most of the talking but instead to ask
open-ended questions and let them talk
and so seek first to understand
before being before seeking to be
understood
and that classic line so yeah
so you're teaching creators how to
become coaches essentially essentially
yeah not necessarily for the end goal of
being a coach although many of them want
to be coaches and it's but really the
idea is how do you monetize a small
audience and you monetize a small
audience not by
building it into a huge audience and
then selling a ten dollar product to
each person or a five dollar product
whatever t-shirts and stuff but instead
if you have a tiny audience you should
sell a higher priced product a more
premium product okay and a very valuable
premium product that genuinely adds a
lot of value as coaching and learning to
coach and learning to become a coach not
only do you get to know your audience
better get to know your niche better and
niching down is so important but you get
to
come up with new ideas what are they
thinking about what video titles to
create what headlines to create what
emails newsletter
subject lines to write down because you
understand how to enter the conversation
going on in their heads so it's a way to
be a good listener to your audience to
qualitatively take them through a
process and one of the things i've been
telling you for your book as well is
take somebody through that process as
you're developing it uh like a small
cohort of people and see how they get on
where did they get stuck and then that's
what we did for our book um kind of
informally through mentoring etc and
then you can kind of and giving public
speak
public speaking as well as a big piece
of that see what questions you get asked
so basically you're honing and iterating
your content to then make it into a
better product and that was the idea
one thing i want to talk to you about so
you've done a fair bit of backpacking
traveling type stuff around like eastern
europe southeast asia that kind of thing
um and offline we were talking about how
over time you developed the ability to
just go up and talk to people and get
involved and like talk to strangers how
how did you go about developing that
kind of confidence yeah because if i
imagine kind of like going to a random
country and then going up to strangers
and like striking up a conversation
even the thought of that just fills me
with dread and same with me so i grew up
very shy and i remember even even when i
was in university there would be these
kind of careers events and everyone
would be kind of standing around with
drinks and kind of networking and i was
extremely uncomfortable in those
environments of like
do you just join a circle of people who
are talking already how do you join that
conversation
and that's something that i really
started to read up about or started to
read up about social dynamics started
read up about attraction and and dating
and how that i i still remember i saw an
advert when i was 15. like sort of
random i was in like ebon's world which
was this i don't know if you remember
that website but it was this
online gaming website
and it was like how to attract the
girlfriend of your dreams or something
and i was like 15 super religious muslim
boy not even having any intention of
getting a girlfriend but i was just so
curious and i started reading and
reading and reading about it and
i've learned so much so it's like it's
quite interesting when nerds kind of put
their mindset on the things that aren't
necessarily nerdy like social dynamics
it's really fascinating stuff and i
think it's really helped me in business
so essentially
i really had to push myself outside of
my comfort zone and that i really had to
just like you get approach anxiety and
you're scared to go and talk to somebody
to go and strike up a conversation you
know funnily enough like
an interesting story just out of the
blue that just came to my mind i saw
somebody this is around
i don't know 2016 ish i saw somebody on
the tube
um on the london underground and it was
this guy and he was wearing this hoodie
and it said facebook on the shoulder and
this is before facebook had a terrible
reputation i never really he was a huge
fan necessarily but i was kind of on
facebook at that time um
so it's not like nowadays the climate is
now
oh that's interesting facebook this guy
maybe he's a face that's so lame is he a
facebook fan like he's such a fan and i
thought maybe he works for them so i i
got on the same carriage and i struck a
conversation with this guy
he turned out to be like
the
global head of of uh marketing the
global head of growth of facebook it was
like a really high up executive at
facebook and he was super friendly and
then he invited me down to the facebook
offices and i got shown around and he
told me the story of how he used to he
was one of the founders of um
uh what was it called a fire something
to do with rss so it was one of the r uh
feed burner i think it was called he was
one of the founders of feedback or one
of the early members and then it was
bought by google and he worked for
google for a number of years and then he
went to facebook and this guy's like now
at amazon and stuff and it was just like
what a cool
um
networking thing to happen just from
talking to a stranger like the
serendipity that can happen from that
another story based on like me getting
over my fear of doing stuff like this is
i got into university by doing this i
got into the university i wanted i was
going down this path of medicine and all
this stuff queen mary i dropped out i
didn't know what i wanted to do i
decided after a lot of soul searching
and drama i talk about that in the book
as well but i decided to
do economics and i wanted to learn about
the developing world i wanted to help
i'm
born in iraq kind of came to the uk when
i was three years old i was like okay
maybe i can help rebuild iraq after the
war and stuff so i thought let me do
this course at soas university which is
uh got of emphasis on developing
economies that'll be interesting i'll
learn about china the middle east africa
et cetera
and but i actually was six months behind
the ucas deadline which was like january
4th this was in june
and i was also i didn't have the grades
because i didn't do the right subjects
and i didn't have so i didn't
so by any stretch of the imagination i
shouldn't have been able to get in
but what i did is i looked up the
undergraduate admissions tutor googled
him
this in those days google like people
didn't have their pictures online as
often but luckily he did it it was like
this low res image of his face is just a
headshot and he was um
he was this professor and he was also
the younger undergraduate admissions
teacher i went to his page and he said
student office hours and this goes back
to the whole thing of like bending rules
as well i've always been a bit i've
never really liked rules i have maybe
that's why i want to start my own
business i didn't like authority so it
was like okay i can't get into
uh this course because i don't have the
grades and i'm six months late okay by
any i shouldn't even bother but okay let
me look this up guy up and let me go and
see if i can convince him i could just
go talk to him so i turned up at like
two just like five minutes to two on
like a tuesday which was during his
office hours i walked down i got into
the university somehow i think he didn't
have barriers at that time to get in i
went up to his i walked down the
corridor and i saw him walking towards
me and i was like oh uh professor can i
you have a moment he's like yeah sure
thinking i'm a student coming for his
student office hours i sat down with him
and i was like okay so here's why i want
to study economics and so on here's why
i want to do this and by the end of my
little
spiel my little pitch where i had
on the train over i was writing bullet
points and stuff in my notebook and he
was like okay tell the admissions office
that i'm going to accept your
application and then i even wrote my
personal statement just for psoas i
didn't even hedge my bets i literally
just said this is what i want i sent it
out and he accepted me and i go in so
this has really changed like pushing
past shyness and that
fear of starting a conversation fear of
initiating has helped me in so many ways
i've built up a lot of rapport skills
which has been interesting which has
helped me in business in so many ways
it's helped me with like dating and
stuff like that like just to be
comfortable to talk and first dates and
stuff when i so it's it's really changed
my life like learning about social
dynamics learning about status learning
about like body language and stuff like
that and then actually learning is more
of a mindset thing than it is about how
you sit and how you talk and how you
project your voice et cetera is a whole
journey so if you were to guide someone
along that path like what are the key
milestones key resources key sort of
things that helped you get from point a
to point point b
it's there are some brutal truths that
you have to accept when it comes to
learning about attraction and some of
them
feel a bit like oh life shouldn't be
this way people should judge people you
know on the contents of their character
rather than how they look and how they
come across and how i don't know how
they behave and what
so
it's a whole rabbit hole to go down but
it's really understanding particularly
for men to understand how
well actually it's not because it's just
about okay let me go back to this i just
realized it's not because when we talk
about business it also applies it's
understanding that human beings are
hierarchical creatures
and that's a hard pill to swallow
because we want to feel like we're an
egalitarian thing and everybody's equal
and we try our best to make it that way
but then there is always something
happening there's a there's the
conscious communication which they say
is only about what they say in
neuro-linguistic programming it's only
about seven percent of actual
communication is the words the content
when most of it is your voice tone your
body language your timing your pauses
your whatever like
so under starting to understand
communication so i've been fascinated by
this persuasion communication it goes
back to marketing it goes back to
coaching
it's just understanding how human beings
work so i did psychology at a level and
one thing that i didn't like about it is
it was about like um mental illness for
the most part it was about like if
somebody's below baseline how do you
deal with that how do you treat them but
what i was much more interested in is
what they call positive psychology is
like
what is it for the average person and so
i studied that and i learned all about
like communication i learned about so
yeah just research
status understand that it's not so the
first level of learning it is like i
need to be more alpha and that's this
really silly and stupid and overly
simplistic way of thinking about it
because that's not how it works
that is a
way over simplification of it it's
actually much more subtle and it's
actually you kind of go full circle
oftentimes you think that you have to
like
you know do do this and you know that
stereotype of like somebody trying to be
more confident than they really are but
once you start to understand it's more
about self-esteem and it's about deeper
transformation
that is actually what changes things uh
another person is mark manson as well
that used to talk about this stuff a lot
which i actually haven't
learned of his content but i learned
about it a little bit from you and i
think he's really on the right track i
like this his stuff anyway um so that
might be a good place to start um yeah
i've kind of it was a long time ago
before i got into business i was like i
was obsessed with this i was like why do
i care so much about popularity why do i
care so much about like how i come
across why do i feel so
um inadequate or insecure you know that
was a lot of my younger kind of teenage
years i had a lot of that issue so i
want to change gears a bit and talk
about talk about the book um i've
already done a video talking about the
book so i kind of want to talk to you
more about the meta the meta game of the
book
um how do you deal with negative reviews
it's funny this goes back to the whole
kind of maybe some people are
wired not literally necessarily
genetically although that plays a role
but maybe because of an inclination
you're always interested in it and you
always learn about it so one thing that
i've always been interested in
is
um like celebrities and how they talk
about how they deal with fame and how
they come across in interviews and stuff
so like one person speaking of like
social dynamics was interesting when he
was younger and he still is very
interesting russell brand so i'll like
i'll be like okay i'll look on youtube
and i'll just see every interview of
russell brandt and i'll just learn that
and i'll kind of i have this um
immersion approach to life of like
immerse yourself in something to learn
about it and i really think that's a
good way to learn things to model others
and immerse yourself in something
so one thing that i learned is from
celebrities talking about haters and
obviously for them it's much more
extreme like um they'll have a lot of
people that really love them and a lot
of people really hate them so i think
i've
um
so i think i've imbibed that so much
that i was okay with it like i was okay
with negative comments one thing that
was quite challenging is when the book
came out
the date was launched so this was this
whole thing this is our first book it's
gonna be published all this the day it
was launched literally
like i think it was like i can't
remember now it was dozens it was like
close to 100 review reviews and ratings
came out for the book on the day it
launched which was like already weird
because like how could people have
already read it
and they were weird like for example
some of the reviews would be like
positive but then it'll be like two
stars and then some of them were just
random some of them were four stars
someone in the one star yeah we're like
that was weird yeah there's some bots
something's happening there's some bots
happening or something going on because
they kind of already read the whole book
it's only just released today it's not
like we're that famous to have this huge
marketing push that people are ready to
buy and stuff so
um that was difficult
and then but at the same time i was just
like oh these must be bots something
weird is happening here so we got in
touch with our publishers and we're like
oh by the way there's a duplicate
there's also a duplica um book issue
where it was like there was two listings
of the book and one of them had all
these negative reviews we're like
there's these weird bad reviews of the
book
but they must be bots
because people kind of read it already
and also there are two listings can you
please merge them together but or sort
out the listings but don't bring the bad
reviews into it because
they're not good anyway i don't want to
start off with bad reviews for the book
and so what did they do they merged the
and the reviews came along with it the
bad reviews came along with it so it was
like okay
all right well anyway so we just have to
get on with this so i don't know it's
almost like i just wasn't that affected
by it i just told myself that this
wasn't it and it's not going to be right
for most people now the book overall has
done really well now we've just hit a
thousand reviews on goodreads and it's
the average rating is 4.1 something so
it's like it's done really well so i get
the occasional bad review no okay that
wasn't for them i always knew it
wouldn't be for everybody so i already
come to terms with that that you can't
be something for everyone and that also
applies to dating that also applies to
like talking to people you just won't
get along with some people and you kind
of and if you have too far of an
internal locus of control you blame
yourself for it yeah yeah i think this
is my problem yeah like you think it's
all about you it's not all about you
it's so self-centered and so
narcissistic to think it's all about how
we approached it they might be having a
bad day they might just have a
personality clash they might have just i
don't know whatever then
somebody might have passed away recently
in their lives who knows i don't know
so yeah it was it's part of that is to
think people have their own [ __ ] i'm not
gonna can't appeal to everybody
and to understand niching down to
understand that actually being
polarizing can be a good thing anyway
yeah and to understand that
if you're
if you want to please everybody then
you're going to be so bland and blah no
one's really be into what you're doing
yeah yes i'm so as you know i'm a fan of
systematically breaking things down so
it sounds like kind of your your
strategy as it were for dealing with the
negative reviews number one understand
that you want for everyone and that's
okay i understand that it's really not
about you a lot of the time maybe it's
just it was it wasn't right for them
um two you said that you had this bot
issue which you can just sort of write
off yeah what were some of the other
things that you kind of imbibed from the
the russell brand ecosystem
around dealing with haters around
celebrities
um
i think i learned early on from learning
about social dynamics and confidence
stuff is that you have to
define your own set of terms for what
success and how to be happy with
yourself
and not to
look to others so one of the big
insights is actually one of the
leadership principles one of the
leadership properties
is actually to
try to gain first-hand knowledge
rather than
like figure out things for yourself
as opposed to just listen to what
everybody else tells you now that could
be taken too far when people are just
like i need to do my own research for
everything obviously that's silly but
this idea of kind of rejecting social
conditioning
wholesale and just to accept everything
as people say it and i think
that is part of getting your validation
externally rather than internally and if
you can
start to build your internal validation
and start to be pleased with yourself
according to your own criteria okay i'm
going to be happy with and and i've kind
of consciously set my criteria to be
productivity based yeah and as i said
i'm honestly really not that productive
of a guy and i and i really really i've
told you this before i really relate to
the whole tim ferriss thing where he's
like people really want to um
journalists always want to follow me
around for the day
and i always say no because it's so
boring i'll just be me pottering around
in my underwear wasting time and just
taking too long in the bathroom and
things like that so it's like that's my
life
so
i think that's that creative thing of
like we're not very systematic we're
kind of and one of my coaches been
telling me like this is how you're
creating you're doing these other things
that in the meantime and you and i'm the
way i am i'm constantly and i'm the 2x
learner as well i'm constantly like
learning and taking in content and
information
that's just how i do things and that's
how it works so for me
that's how i set my own validation for
myself and therefore i know okay i think
i'm proud of what i've done so i was
really proud of what i did for the book
and i was happy with it now obviously
i'm gonna i can't take away the external
validation seeking thing completely yeah
it's gonna be there um thankfully the
book has done well so i'm
even got awards for it which we were not
even expecting it blew our minds so
it just shows that the process worked
the process of like iterating and
starting and we followed that whole you
know the whole tech startup software
thing of like doing an mvp and and
testing out and iterating and improving
it and i think that's why it works okay
that seems like a very sensible way to
approach approach stuff
because it's like i think i think for me
over the last few years i've gotten
somewhat immune to negative comments on
youtube
but i just know that you know if and
when this book ever comes out two years
from now that if there are negative
reviews then that is going to hit me on
a level that is different to a youtube
video yeah
to be honest i expected more hate
i expected more and therefore what what
little we got was like oh
not too bad
we expected there to be more it's like i
over prepared and maybe that was a good
thing so because i expected people to be
like what do you mean unfair
what are you talking about is about hard
work yeah what do you mean it's not a
meritocracy of course it's america like
i expected much more pushback so why
would i had all these like
one of the things that you try and do is
you kind of try and poke holes in your
own arguments so i think i did that a
lot yeah and i addressed a lot of
objections in the book like
every time i said unfair advantages we
don't mean an unethical or illegal
advantage
you know i didn't need to keep saying
that i probably overdid that but like
that i kept wanting to like emphasize
i'm not trying to say like cheat the
system yeah or or you know be corrupt or
something i'm talking about just like
basic unfair people knew that's what we
meant and i kind of so i think what
helped is over like to expect
to expect to get a lot of pushback and
then not to get that to be like
pleasantly surprised yeah what was it
like writing a book with a co-author
yeah you have to really understand what
each of you brings to the table
so i think um ash was the ideas man and
he was an amazing sounding board and he
came up with the whole thing the unfair
advantages came about from ash
the miles framework came about from i
developed it further i i poked holes in
it i i put it together into a whole
system i think i'm good at that
conceptual thinking so i like i put it
into a whole system and into the whole
okay what if people say this okay how
does mindset people will say mindset is
my biggest unfair advantage what would
you say to that what do what do you say
to people who say working hard
is my advantage is my is that an unfair
advantage where do you draw the line
between an unfair advantage and an
earned advantage you spoke about it as
fair play in your video which some
people think is in the book some people
like when they interview me they'll be
like oh so why do you think fair play i
was like yeah
you watched ali's video which is a great
video about it um and essentially
it's just doing all that thinking so you
have to know what each of you brings to
the table and one of the things again i
go back to steven pressfield he was
talking about how i think he was
in nobody wants to read your [ __ ] which
is one of my favorite books about like
how to create compelling content and
storytelling and stuff which i've
recommended to you a lot is he talks
about how he was working with a writing
partner to write scripts for hollywood
and this writing partner just would
wouldn't really turn up at the time they
said they would and he'd be fed up
waiting for him and he and then he
realized that this this guy isn't a
writer writer this guy's a writer editor
and he's the writer writer and that was
he what he he had to do the writing and
this guy would come and edit and give
his thoughts and give his feedback on it
and i think
that was essentially the relationship
with me and actually it was like um i
did the actual writing for the most part
um there are bits here and there that
are written by him but essentially it
wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for
him he brought his name to it he brought
his ideas to it he brought his whole it
gave it a lot of clout and status we had
the justice ipo 1.5 billion pounds 2.4
billion dollars so you have to think
about what each of you brings to the
table and
he's given me so much confidence and
pushed me so much to go and do public
speaking to go and mentor people and
that was something that i hadn't done so
there has been this is how we've split
up ourselves
i'm a big believer in business partners
and co-authors and working with people
as opposed to doing everything yourself
and that's a big theme in the book too
um so i'm i was working on a draft of
chapter one this morning which is all
about like why you shouldn't really set
hard goals and you should actually focus
on setting easy goals
and that's sort of the
sort of somewhat counter-narrative
argument i'm trying to make that screw
smart goals focus on goals that are
within your control and uh once you've
got a goal then thinking of think of it
purely as a destination and then just
completely forget about it because
at that point fixating on it or even
thinking about it at all is at least for
me like not a very helpful thing
and it's how and it should be like you
know oh imagine the the treasure at the
end of the rainbow and then that will
motivate you to do the thing but at
least for me i find that imagining the
treasure at the end of the rainbow does
not at all motivate me to do the thing
and instead focusing on the bits that i
can control focusing on the journey
focusing on okay my only task right now
is to just
write one really shitty first draft of
this next of this chapter i'm on 2700
words cool let's just keep on going and
then any time i think oh but like this
sounds bad or oh but i should probably
edit it oh here or oh but like i i think
nope stay on task enjoy the journey i've
got my music in the background i've got
my coffee i've got my oat milk whatever
and i'm just like banging stuff out
speed speed running writing the first
chapter oh cool um and that seems to be
working
but i often find myself like
i think one of the issues with these
sorts of non-fiction books is that
really it's not really about what's true
it is about what's useful
i think in a self-help book like this
like you know james clear you know
atomic habits the four things that make
a habit stick it may not matter that
this mental model is 100 true yeah but
if it's a useful way of modeling the
information and it's true enough that
people can use it and apply it to their
lives
you know similar to left brain right
brain analogy like
that's not actually how the brain works
like oh right brain is creative and left
brain is not but like
just having that model is still somewhat
useful where you think you know if
someone said it describes themselves as
a more like right brain kind of person
or if someone says oh i'm really high on
trait extroversion like you know the
ocean personality traits it's not
actually how the brain works it's just a
model that we've taken to put on top of
it to kind of simplify things
and as long as it's useful it's all good
but at the same time i i keep on like
poking holes in my own argument where
i'm like yeah but you know you know my
point is that for me setting more
achievable and easier goals is better
than setting harder goals but also if
you look at the evidence actually
there's a bunch of evidence that setting
challenging goals is better than setting
easy goals and like what the hell how do
you oh and i keep on kind of second
guessing and guessing myself how do you
how do you deal with that right
yeah this is important and i think what
you're doing is you're thinking on paper
it's like what i said about coaching
like i said that um one of the biggest
takeaways is you don't know what you
think until you hear yourself say it
and it's similarly with writing that's
why writing's are valuable that's why
journaling is sort of a good analog to
coaching if specifically if you follow a
good structure it's
you're figuring out what you think by
writing it down
that's what's happening there
and
i'm impressed that you're you're
disciplined enough to not edit as you
write because i still ended up doing
that quite a bit but as much the more i
stayed away from it the better it was um
yes so going back to the whole idea of
mental models i think this is huge and i
talk about that in the book i was like
so here so why did i went meta and said
okay look there's two
two models extreme models one is success
is all luck and the other success is all
hard work and merited and earned and
success if it's all fate and luck and
unearned that's the other one the truth
is in the middle and then i talked about
this kind of tension between the two so
that's one approach is you could
describe it as a tension and you could
talk about how yes you could do hard
goals but you can also do easy goals and
here's how to think about it
but yeah the whole thing about mental
models is fascinating that's one thing
that i got out of economics is is in
economics it's too complicated just like
the human body it's way too complicated
any guru out there telling you well this
is to burn fat and this one's just
bloody may turn your body alkaline or
some [ __ ] like that it's all
oversimplified for the most part
nonsense for the most part even when
they sound like they're using scientific
language and they're saying insulin this
and ghrelin and leptin and all this
stuff it's like okay yeah but it's
actually super super super complicated
and this is an oversimplification but
you know what the patients whose doctors
tell them well you know the saturated
fat that you're eating is just firing up
and clogging your arteries that's not
actually how it works but if it's a
simple model for them to use and if
saturated fats were actually bad which
is very
it's a whole other killer fish but the
point is that you want to help people to
change their behavior and transform so
this goes back to the online course
something so you could be a youtuber and
you can be an educational youtuber
obviously you could do comedy you could
do whatever you could do drama the point
is to be an educational youtuber is a
whole category and you could then teach
physics and maths but then there's
another sub-segment of educational which
i said transformational creators you're
helping people to transform and that's
what you're doing with your book you're
helping people transform what is that
that's mindset and behavior change
ultimately it's behavior change really
because that will also change the
mindset and the identity and all of that
stuff so
for behavior change how do you motivate
people to change their behavior you
oversimplify
that's one thing and then you make power
yeah exactly you empower and
oversimplify to give them clarity to be
like okay simple i just need to do this
yeah
um
now that's an overly simplistic
you know self-help book which does that
it's kind of too can be too far so you
might want to make it deeper and talk
about how the people go back and forth
but here's what's worked for me and
here's what i want to do so the the
phrase i always like to go back to is
the map is not the terrain
well the map is not the territory
so whatever you're mapping is not going
to be the actual thing otherwise it's a
useless map imagine you had a one-to-one
map that had every single detail that's
not useful map so what you're trying to
do is you're mapping reality and you're
saying okay here's one way here's our
approach is set easy goals as you call
it and basically are you saying process
oriented goals in that sense uh yeah
more or less yeah so what we what you
have to do is set your own glossary and
start to define your own terms and then
within your own universe and what makes
sense to others because one of the
things is uh initially when we're using
the word productivity and you say well
productivity isn't just about output
over time and you had a great podcast
episode with unj jade and you were
discussing that and
well i mean you have to realize that
you're taking liberties with the word
productivity yeah to include um like
intentionality and meaning and like
enjoyment and joy and all that jazz
which wouldn't traditionally be
in a technical dictionary definition of
progress and therefore you could say
let's redefine productivity to mean this
yeah and then i can do what i want
because now you've laid out mine you've
redefined it got it so when i'm thinking
like screw hold goals set easy goals
then that's like the clickbaity title
which kind of be like oh that's
interesting um like or like smart goals
are dumb here's here's how you set goals
instead
but and then they're like okay that that
encourages me to read on and then it's
like okay
there's some new ones here like there's
a spectrum as with anything as with
everything
here's how i'd like to think of it yeah
there are some people who find this this
approach useful i personally find this
approach useful and i think the balance
between them is like ten percent of my
goals i'm happy for them to be outcome
based but 90 i want to be process based
and for me i personally find that that's
the best yeah sort of
whatever i had this exact same thing
writing the book yeah i'll be writing a
chapter and i'd keep keep going back and
forth my arguments well
nevertheless
but although yeah and it's just
constantly hedging and caveat and it's
like okay but you need to figure out
what you're trying to say here
but you have to i feel like you have to
go through that thrashing
as part of the process yeah you're now
in that thrashing mode where you're like
back and forth back and forth yeah i
find that as i'm writing my my thoughts
are solidifying and i sometimes find
myself just like oh that's that's
actually a really good point i just made
like where did that come from and then
exactly
and and so now it's like one one issue
i'm having right now is that for a lot
of the a lot of the chapters i don't
feel like i have enough content and so
i'm tempted to
you know i was figuring out my calendar
link figuring out okay who can i contact
to help me in this in this in these
domains i now have sufficient clout that
if i were to email like a university
researcher who's done publications about
goal setting and be like hey i'm writing
a book published by whatever whatever
whatever i would love to interview
they'd probably say yes
uh but then i was thinking
maybe that's actually even that is just
procrastination and my first step is to
just get stuff down on paper so i know i
can just like expunge my own brain of
everything that i think i want to say
and then when it comes to the editing
stage we can look at where the arguments
going i can sort of team up with my
editor times twos to figure out okay
what are we trying to say here where do
we need extra evidence where do we need
an expert opinion and now let's reach
out to professor whoever from stanford
who researches goal setting it's not an
academic paper exactly it's not you're
not
doing research and running studies and
then you know publishing your findings
that's not what writing a book is
writing a book is actually just about
helping people to
level up in their lives it's a
self-development book anyway yeah yeah i
think like
maybe people listening to this will find
that like a tough pill to swallow i
wonder because i feel like
i i feel like there's there can
sometimes be an attitude that like
self-help books are a bit of a scam and
i guess what we're saying is like
yes yes they are a bit of a scam because
they're not like 100 true
but
it also depends on like what's what's
what's the objective like it is a bit of
a scam to say well the only thing you
need to do to lose weight is like eat
for your calories than you consume
it's more complicated than that but
really if that's the thing that gets you
to lose weight like the the objective is
to lose weight the objective is not to
have a perfectly academically rigorous
work of art exactly or like the incident
hypothesis of like it's all about
insulin it's all about carbs the reason
you're not losing weight is because you
keep eating carbs and if your insulin is
elevated then your blood sugar can't be
uh
sorry the glucose can't be released or
the fat the fat is trapped in the fat
cells and it's like that model really
helps a lot of people to lose a lot of
weight but it's not strictly true it's
actually much more complicated it's kind
of true there is there is some of that
but there's also the calories thing and
actually you can eat you know a low fat
diet and lose weight and that can
totally work even though it's harder
it's just a heart in my experience and
in most people's experience it's much
harder to stick to a low fat diet than
it's just but then also fat is got
vitamins and
the point is
everything now if you go to economics
there are people out there say economics
is a complete scam they couldn't even
predict the 2008 crash what's wrong
what's the point of all this it's all
just it's all just mental masturbation
it's all it is it's just constant and
actually if you think about social
studies oh um or social sciences i mean
oh it's all a scam it's all a complete
scam you can't it's not a hard science
it's a soft science it's all complete
nonsense it's all just twiddling and i
mean there's some truth to some of that
i think there is but there's also a lot
of value in it too so you really have to
understand the nuance of everything and
that can be said not just about
self-development books that's actually
in fact that's actually more practical
than a lot of the things i just
mentioned yeah which you can think of
more as scams uh at the end of the day
when you go into really theoretical
physics models i think you have the same
issues i'm not sure but i think so so
yeah whatever
even maths at that advanced level
becomes extremely theoretical you start
working with imaginary numbers and stuff
but yeah it's it's a case of like
understanding what it's for yeah
understanding that you're just it's
really it's like you're on
a book is sort of an immersive
experience where it's like
it's almost like a good way to hone it
down is into a ted talk like one way to
think about what you're trying to say is
that what would you say in a 20 minute
ted talk
i'd actually encourage you to do that i
did that for our book it really helped
it really helped to distill okay what is
it in a nutshell yeah how do i put this
across yeah um
and yeah so it's yeah so i think i think
i've got the 20 minute ted talk version
because the way i was thinking of it is
what would i say if i were making a
video about this right and then now my
next question is okay i know what what i
would say in a video about the whole
book and in fact over the last few
months being i've been interviewed on a
few podcasts where i have basically
delivered the book in 10 minute bite
size format i'm like okay cool this
makes sense on a broad level
now what i'm thinking is like okay for
each individual chapter what would i say
how would i make a video about this
topic and for me the mental model of
like i'm gonna i'm making a video about
this thing
feels so much easier having
a because i've done it before but also
in my head a book is a big deal whereas
when i'm making a video i trust myself
more i recognize that you know i
wouldn't make a video called how to set
goals and make a video called how i set
goals and all of a sudden i have
artistic license to say whatever the
hell i want because it's obvious that
it's this is not me trying to be an
expert and give you the give you the
goods academically this is my personal
philosophy this is the things that have
kind of worked for me and my own
personal journey of transformation
through this whole goal-setting stuff
yeah and so when i think about it in
video format i think i give myself more
permission when i think about it in
writing a book it feels harder and so i
think it kind of kind of comes back to
this idea of lowering the bar lowering
the stakes in a way setting easier goals
it is an easier goal for me to set just
to say i'm going to make a video about
this topic of goal setting it's a lot
harder goal for me to say i'm going to
write a book chapter and so can i hack
my brain into thinking that really what
i'm doing is creating a video and then
leave it to the editors to remove the in
this video and replace it with in this
chapter and all that kind of stuff
whatever works i feel like a lot of
self-development or um getting past
procrastination or productivity whatever
is just mind-hacking it's sort of just
trick tricking yourselves with little
things tricking your mind um i think i
read about michael jordan he would find
a way to motivate himself for every
single game that he played he'll just do
oh there's probably a kid up there who's
never seen me play he's come for the
first time see michael jordan play let
me show him what it's like it's like he
has like there's
people you have to actually actively
it's like in a relationship you have to
actively work on the relationship yeah i
think we always just assume that yeah it
should work if you're in love it should
be the soul mate and it should work we
have to actually actively do it and the
same thing with just getting our brains
to work how we want them to work we have
to fool our brains it's a weird concept
because it's like it's in our brains
ourselves but it's not it's
so we have to do what we can and
whatever works works um and you have to
understand that that you're gonna appeal
to a certain audience like this is one
big thing about like the way i see it is
like we've gone from broadcast mediums
where there was like one channel on
television two channels three channels
and then it started the proliferation of
different cable channels and thousands
of them and then the internet and then
everything could sub-niche down into
niches and niches
and if you look back on like
self-development world in the 80s 90s it
was like tony robbins with cassette
tapes and he would try to do a
one-size-fits-all for everybody
listening but nowadays you could try to
pin it down to
this sort of person you know this book
is for introverts this book is for you
know doctors this book is for whatever
like this video is for that so i think
you have to realize that who it's going
to connect with and we're not all the
same and that's a big thing is like i
say is like as
like medicine's becoming more
personalized down to people's genetics
and down to how people respond to
certain things so should advice be
personalized to the different type of
people and so a big piece of this is
going to be what worked for you
and it's also going to be to for you to
do a dry run alien i'm going to push you
again to do that because you have to try
it on a group of people
and
it's fine if it's your fans because
that's kind of who you're targeting is
that that's your niche in a way the i
mean the biggest growth hack to finding
your niche and your target audience is
to look at your audience if you have an
audience and you look at who are they
who are my most you know the best
audience the people who really love what
i do who really get a lot of value from
it yeah
get them and see what systems can help
them
in in what you're teaching in your book
test it out on them see where do they
get stuck see where you can
communicate it differently where you can
frame it differently where you can give
different metaphors analogies etc for
them to really ah that makes sense and
to be activated to doing it yeah so i
think i'm going to have a large amount
of uh sort of beta testing each draft of
the chapter on a subset of the audience
um i was watching julian shapiro's
writing masterclass yesterday which is
really really good um and he talks about
he just invented these terms but they're
really helpful again like fake knowledge
that is actually really helpful uh the
the dopamine intro and the dopamine line
line count
uh where his model is basically what
makes good non-fiction writing
uh and it's 75 of it is novelty like if
someone feels like oh that's novel they
get a dopamine hit and they want to keep
on reading interesting and the other 25
is like the storytelling and the how you
deliver it and stuff but but really it's
about starting with novelty and so his
thing was when he's deciding what to
write about if he's researching
something he's
as as he reads a book and highlights
something
or he makes a note he scores it out of
five in terms of how novel he found it
at the time because inevitably a year
later when you look at the same
information you're like obviously i knew
this all along and you start to you get
hedonically adapt to your own
level of knowledge
so
what he does is that the introduction
needs to be sufficiently novel either in
terms of being counter-intuitive or in
terms of being counter-narrative like
counter-intuitive as in
you thought this but actually this thing
counter-narrative everyone is telling
you x but actually why let me tell you
let me explain boom and then people are
like oh okay they get a different mean
hit and they keep on reading
and what he does when he's giving asking
people for feedback is that he just
sends a doc to each person and he says
all i want you to do is just highlight
the bits where you thought whoa that's
interesting that's literally all i want
you to do because he was like asking
friends for writing feedback is kind of
hard like everyone's going to tell you
different things no one really knows how
to give feedback but he asked them what
did you find surprising then bang you
sorted uh david pearl has this other one
like the cribs method like you know
highlight bits that were confusing
repeated insightful boring or surprising
something like that and then and then
for people to give you feedback all they
have to do is go go through the thing
with a highlighter in different colors
so i'm definitely planning to to do a
lot of that style of things
um i think in an ideal world i would
have like my own coaching cohort and
take them through the process and get
real-time feedback and stuff
i feel like i have
little enough time in my life already
that adding the additional
bull lake of that would be probably too
much effort but feel free to disagree
with me am i bullshitting myself
definitely because you keep telling me
that your number one priority is the
book and you want the book to be good
yeah but then you won't you that's too
much effort to make it do you think the
book would be significantly better with
a live cohort than it would be with
people giving me this kind of feedback
on the right really because i think
because
what do you actually want from the book
like a big piece of it is people going
this is a great book and it's very
readable and as a page turner okay so
that's that's great and that's a
brilliant goal and i completely agree
with that and endorse that yeah and
you'll get that from
people uh the writing feedback even yeah
yeah but for people to actually
transform their lives from yes and to
get genuine long-term like oh my god
i've really got to recommend you this
book it changed my life yeah as opposed
to yeah it was a great read yeah
now that is when you're really thinking
about the long tail that's when you're
really thinking about value
like ultimately all goes down to this
what is value okay okay so let's say i
want to do a drive a dry cohort a dry
run how would you suggest i approach
this
you know what like yeah don't forget you
can actually
you obviously need to be heavily
involved yeah but you there you don't
need to literally be in every single
part of it yeah actually in a way in a
way if you delegate some of the
teaching or coaching or whatever
however we find that delineation between
teaching and coaching because there are
different things obviously but
you want your system to actually be
teachable by somebody else as well
so that's an extra layer um
we have five writers on the team five
writers could be like hey george
do you fancy reading this thing that
i've written and getting my philosophy
on goal setting and try teaching it to
some people a resume call and see what
happens but also remember that writers
are not necessarily teachers yeah so
think about teachers and think about
coaches
and obviously that can be obviously
that's teachable that's a
learnable skill
but it might not be what they want to do
this is what i'm trying to say okay so
let's say okay so let's say i'm because
like for example we've got a live code
of youtube academy running right now at
the end of the live session i could just
be like guys feel free to stick around
for an extra half an hour and i want to
test some book ideas on you
for example and there'll be several
dozen to several hundred people on a
zoom call who will then be receptive to
giving advice and feedback and stuff
yeah i mean that's the thing you have to
think about what is the end result that
people want out of your book yeah and
you have to really figure that out and
then understand that okay if this maps
onto the part-time youtuber academy for
people trying to start a youtube channel
et cetera oh it does actually yeah if it
does then
do that but then also try and test it
with people with different goals as well
just to yeah just to give it something
yeah to give it some testing i mean i've
got a bunch of smartphones that could
probably point me in the direction of
each other i would totally integrate it
into your syllabus yeah
why haven't you
[Laughter]
good point
i could do that how how can that be yeah
just integrate what you're going to
teach in the book into the ptyaa
syllabus and
see how people respond to it yeah um we
didn't we didn't actually use many beta
readers we didn't actually do that
process much yep
okay a little bit but not hardly yeah
because i've kind of got some of the
ideas in my head and so i could just
incorporate them into some of the
sessions
and be like interlude goal setting
yeah
or you can
just do an internal launch
you could just do it to your newsletter
subscribers say hey if you want to join
this cohort
i would kind of i would
it'll just be keener to do it separately
i know you want to integrate into
something else but you can make it very
minimalist
you can't i ran a course the last course
i ran it was just uh 90 minutes a week
of lessons and then an hour of coaching
oh i've got it i've got it
during our live sessions when people are
in breakout rooms we always have a bunch
of people left in the lobby because
they're at work or they're like kids or
whatever you shouldn't do that do you
know why why people won't go to breakout
rooms just to be in that session oh yes
they won't go into the breakout rooms i
know that because whenever there's more
content people think they just want more
content yeah you know why because it's
less effort
yeah it's less have to just sit there
rather than engaging i'd rather just
consume content yeah you give me the
choice
this is quite an early i used to
literally read science textbooks and
then when it gets to the exercise which
is the homework for that night when i
was a kid i'll just be like
and i'll turn the page and i'll keep
reading science yeah and i think one of
the reasons that i did well in science
is because i used to like reading the
textbook but i didn't used to like doing
exercises and it would have been better
if i had done it but it's all right okay
um
yeah
i really think well
we can come up with something maybe we
can i mean i don't mind collaborating
with your net
okay yeah yeah how do we do it yeah i'll
do it we'll
we'll figure out something we'll do some
course design maybe coach that cohort or
something yeah figure this out yeah just
do it as like a free thing use us as
subscribers post it on twitter be like
you have to then explain like let's say
just as an example yeah i don't know
about my schedule etc but we'll figure
this out but let's say imagine i do it
so you have to then distill that
knowledge to me and then i'll be like
ali wait what yeah i'll already be
picking holes in it just for me to
understand it yeah and then i'll go
through another thing for me to explain
to students then we see how they respond
to it
yeah
even more hands off for you
that's very good because
it should be kind of viral like it
should be able to transmissible it could
be quite transmissible
okay
interesting
yeah that could work nicely
yeah because i kind of know what i want
to say for each chapter you want to see
where people get stuck when they're
actually trying to put into packages and
then and then also and then you can turn
this into an online course
yeah i mean yeah i i plan to at some
point but like yeah but then it's even
more well designed for it
but then but don't i'm not taking
anything away from how important it is
to get feedback on the writing oh yeah i
mean that's the whole separate thing
that's like the what makes it a patient
what makes it interesting what makes it
actually good but
that's not the thing that makes it
easier yeah it is easier the stylistic
bit you can hire people who really you
can hire joke writers you can hire
storytellers you can i mean i'm not
saying necessarily this is the approach
but i'm saying the core of it is how you
can help people to transform
and to change their mind you know books
don't have to be like an online course
where you literally
change your life they don't have to be
sometimes they're just a refreshing new
take on something yeah like one of the
things my writing coach says is that
just think about what is the smallest
transformation that you want the reader
to have one thing like if they could
only take away one thing what would it
be
and for that it would be the phrase make
it fun
uh if they're gonna take away two things
it would be make it easy and make it fun
and honestly if they just take away
those two concepts that will transform
their productivity forever
um and now i just need to convert that
into actual stuff nice all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
gonna be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye